what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and it's finally
happening everyone is now converging on
the same spot
the main battlefield for the epic climax
of the spade kingdom war arc the final
showdown is happening
and asta and the rest of the black bulls
are about to join the main battle
along with many many other important
characters
this is now on all out war
so let's get into it if you enjoyed the
black lover content here on the channel
and you want us to keep it going
please leave a like and comment it
really does
help and if you're new to anime out pro
or maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed
yet make this the video that you
subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
if you don't want to miss future videos
you really have to go through the
trouble of hitting that bell and then
selecting the option that says
all also if you are looking for a crazy
weekly
anime podcast then i have the podcast
for you
along with my friends not stockwind
briggs i host a podcast every week
called rant cafe it is available for
free exclusively on spotify so check it
out
link in the description finally this
video will of course contain
black clover manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution
you have been warned okay so we start
off
in the aftermath of asta's incredible
one-shotting of that
massive ancient demon yes the demon
really is down and out
which means that asta in his new devil
union form
really was able to cut him down with
just one unbelievable swing
of the demon slayer's sword that is
beyond
impressive when we consider just how
strong and resilient
these ancient demons are and it is now
absolutely clear that asta is on a whole
new level of power
but now that the ancient demon has been
destroyed and the clover kingdom capital
has been saved
asta has another problem he needs to get
to the spade kingdom capital to help in
the
fight against the dark triad but the
spate kingdom capital
is very far away who knows how long this
trip is going to take asta if he tries
to get there on his own
and since noct is currently busy trying
to stay alive
noct can not use his shadow magic to
just teleport
osta into the spade kingdom given just
how bad the situation
is inside the spade kingdom palace after
the early opening of the tree of
cliffhoth
if asta tried to get to the spate
kingdom by conventional means
he would probably end up being too late
to save knox
and the others moreover not long after
he defeats the ancient demon
asta's time in the devil union form runs
out
and he reverts to his normal form and
liebe reverts back to his chibi form
the two of them and gimodello suddenly
dropped from the sky where they had been
flying back when they were still in the
devil union form
but instead of crashing to the ground
they fall right through a portal
and are transported to another location
we don't actually see the face of the
mage who cast
the portal spell but this has to be
finral's
spatial magic once asta and the two
devils arrive
in the secondary location they are
greeted by half a dozen people
we don't see the faces of these people
we only see the bottom of their legs
but asta is clearly excited to see these
guys
so this has to be finral and the other
black bulls
those high-heeled boots must belong to
my girl vanessa
and presumably gray is also there along
with gauche
magna and gordon now i don't want to get
too deep into like a shoe and feet
analysis here to determine who is who
but i think it's safe to say that finral
and the other black bulls are about to
accompany asta to the spade kingdom
and of course thanks to finral's spatial
magic they can get there much quicker
i have to say that i am very excited to
see the other black bulls back in action
especially magnus since he's really been
on the sidelines for quite some time
magna spent the time skip training on
his own after he was told that he was
too weak to benefit from the spirit
guardian training
i have a strong feeling that magna
unlocked some impressive new power-ups
during the time skip
and i think that in this coming battle
he is going to prove himself
to everyone the chapter then switches
focus to the spade kingdom capital
those lower tier devils who emerged from
the palace are attacking the capital
and the resistance forces and the clover
kingdom infiltrators are doing their
best to fight off these heinous devils
sally is using her gel magic and makusa
north is using
his snow magic to keep the devils at bay
while they evacuate the civilian
population
and it turns out that makusa has the
ability to summon a bunch of snowman
golems
and use them in battle this is actually
funny because makusa's voice actor is
daisuke sakuma
a member of the band called snowman so
makuu's magic is definitely a reference
to that
but beyond just being a reference i
gotta admit that having a snow based
power
in a snowy place like the spade kingdom
is actually really useful
we'll see if makusa ends up doing
something important in the story
or if he just ends up being a minor side
character now
as all of this is happening valtos is
using his spatial magic to evacuate the
civilians and transport them somewhere
safe
and the uncrowned undefeated lion king
sekei is there too standing by and
getting ready to annihilate the devils
if the others can't get the job done
without him
honestly as long as sekei is there on
the battlefield i'm not worried
meanwhile fugolian shows up with
salamander
and absolutely scorches a bunch of the
devils
i was happy to see fugolian in action
once again and he is definitely one of
the strongest mages
on the battlefield right now but even
with fugoleon there
the sheer number of devils is just so
huge that even salamander can't scorch
them all in time
just as it looks like a few of the
devils are going to break through and
devour
some of the spade kingdom civilians
there is a sudden flash of light
and the devil attackers are vaporized
before they have time to harm
anyone a powerful rune enforced magic
was able to take out the devils while
not doing
any harm to the humans and this shocks
the spade kingdom resistance fighters
they've never seen anything like this
magic suddenly
the entire heart kingdom gang appears
including luck noel sacrae mimosa
gaia leo charmy poetry and more
i knew that these guys were bound to
show up eventually
but i have to say that this was a truly
phenomenal entrance
and now we really do have an all out
war the infiltration squad from the
clover kingdom
the spade kingdom resistance the heart
kingdom gang
party and the elves they're all here and
you better believe that asta and the
rest of the black bulls are about to
arrive
as well all of these newly powered up
characters are about to face off against
the strongest villains
in the history of black clover we have
the dark triad at one hundred percent of
their devil power
we have the highest tier devils from the
tree of cliffhoth including
of course lilith and namah but we can
assume that other devils will emerge
from the cliff
off as well including lucifer himself
this will be such an amazing final
showdown
and this is truly a fitting climax for
this incredible
arc let's be real the battle inside the
spade kingdom palace was looking pretty
bad for noct and the others
after morris sped up the opening of the
cliff off and lilith and namaste
showed up however with the heart kingdom
gang now here
and asta and the other black bulls on
the way there is
hope for victory man this is going to be
great i expect phenomenal action
incredible teamwork fighting in multiple
locations
with many different types of magic all
working together and
a ton of twists and turns we may even
get some major deaths
because these devil villains really are
on an entirely different level from
anything that we've seen before
so we have to be prepared to lose some
characters we care about
during this showdown obviously i hope we
don't lose any of the black bulls
because they are
such a great squad one of the coolest
squads in the history of anime in my
personal opinion but
as fun as it is to watch these epic
fights we have to remember that fights
have consequences and this is going to
be very dangerous
for our heroes so yeah there might be
casualties we'll have to wait and see
let me know what you guys think are you
excited that all out war
is finally here and do you think that we
might lose any important characters
during the course of this battle also
how will asta make his entrance and who
do you think that austin liebe
are going to fight first will it be a
dante rematch
will they fight those new overpowered
devils from the cliffhoth
or someone else definitely share your
thoughts down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this black clover video
and you want us to keep it coming with
the block clover content please leave a
like
to let me know it really does help and
if you're new to the channel or maybe
you haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications don't forget to check
out my weekly anime podcast
the rant cafe podcast available on
spotify for free
link in the description a big thank you
to all of our anime outpour patrons for
making videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple of lord twigo
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans
including ingrata the world a quiet
respect pate heffa liam thompson
algertal dr cortman johnny boy draws
emperor otaku spidey life chanel baked
buddhist and tungsten tarkis
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers on hell cruise
anatoly kazatsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica kaylafond
rathune de ora alicia octor bonnie parks
hinokami and water the red-haired raven
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games ted no ted deadly saint matthew
cruz and
anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us on
patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patreon exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you